[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم في حصاد الليله معكم في الوقت
الذي احدث
وتتفاعله اخرى
التي تستقبل الرئيس
وفي مواضيع الحصاد هذه الليله
[موسيقى]
بعد 300 يوم على الحرب في اوكرانيا
زيلانسكي في اول زياره خارجيه له والوجهه
واشنطن اعلان امريكيه عن حزمه مساعدات
جديده تشمل منظومه صواريخ باتريات بيقول
الجزيره ان المساعدات الامريكيه تغيرت
وفقا الاوضاع الميدانيه والتكتيكات
الروسيه ومسك تقول انه لا توقعات ايجابيه
من زياره زيلانكي وتشدد على ان زياده
المساعدات لكيف تفاقم الصراع
روسيا والصين واسئله بشان حدود الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مباحثات رفيعه المستوى في
بيجين تزامنا مع مناورات بحريه مشتركه
يصف الشراكه الاستراتيجيه بين البلدين
بالخيار الاستراتيجي طويل الامد ومدفيديف
يؤكد ان الشراكه مع الصين بلا حدود وفي
تصريح للجزيره البيت الابيض يقول انه
يراقب التعاون الروسيه الصيني عن كثب
بعد وفاته رهن الاسر سلطات الاحتلال ترفض
تسليم جثه الاسير ناصر ابو حميد لعائلته
ترديد فلسطينيه وعائلته شهيد ترفض اقامه
بيت عزاء له لحين تسليم الجثه ووزير
الدفاع الاسرائيلي يرجع السبب لضرورات
امنيه تتعلق بتفاوض بشان تبادل الاسرى
وفي لقائنا اليوميه قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه ناقشنا قرار وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيلي لبنيجانس عدم تسليم جثمان
الشهيد ناصر ابو حميد اذا ما قال انه
تقدير للموقف الامني وبتوسيعته من الجهات
الامنيه والجيش لضروره تتعلق بالمفاوضات
على عقد صفقات تبادل للاسرى والمفقودين
الاسرائيلي
رايكم بهذا الموضوع كنا قد طرحنا عليكم
السؤال تحت اي بنك يندرج القرار
الاسرائيلي احتجاجا جثمان الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد والاشاره لصفقه اسره
الاجابه جاءت على النحو التاليه صوت نحو
49 في المئه بالقول انها السياسه عامه
للتعامل مع جثامين الاسرى في حين راى نحو
51 في المئه انها مؤشرا على صفقه تبادل في
الافق
هذا السؤال
صفحه التصويت عبر مسح رمز كيو ار الذي
يظهر الان على الشاشه
لقاءنا على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا
نتطرق خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيا
ودوليا وهذا الموضوع المتعلق بجثمان
الاسير نصر ابو حميد ستكون له مساحه نقاش
اضافيه خلال الحصاد الليله
[موسيقى]
الان الى واشنطن التي تستقبل الرئيس
الرئيس الاوكراني من جانب الرئيس الامريكي
جوبا ايضا في البيت الابيض هذا هذه
الزياره التي وصل فيها زينكي الى الولايات
المتحده في اول زياره خارجيه له منذ
اندلاع الحرب قبل 300 يوم الرئيس
الاوكراني قال ان زيارته لواشنطن جاءت لكي
يشكر الرئيس
على دعمهم ولتقليبهم همم الانتصار في
المعركه بحسب بتعبيره قال بايدا نبيل ان
بلاده تؤيد سلامه عاجلا في اوكرانيا
وشدد النواشم ستستمر في تعزيز قدره
اوكرانيا للدفاع عن نفسها وانها ستزودها
ببطاريات صواريخ باتريت كما ستدرب
الاوكرانيين على استخدامها بدقه
وفي تصريح ان الجزيره قال منسق الاتصالات
الاستراتيجيه في البيت الابيض جون كربي ان
مساعداتي لاوكرانيا تغيرت مع تغيري مجريات
المعركه
والتكتيكات الروسيه
معنى الان من البيت الابيض
وفادي اهلا بكما ابدا معك وجد اذا
الزياره لها جدول حافل ما الذي تحقق من
الاجنده حتى الان وما الذي ننتظره
نعم لنبدا بما تحقق ليسكي ليلى ربما وهو
اعلان الرئيس
كافيه المكتب الرئاسي البيضاوي بان
الولايات المتحده سوف تزود اوكرانيا
بمنظومه باتريوت الدفاعيه هذه هذا ربما
اكبر انجاز بالنسبه
الرئيس الاوكراني كان يطلب يطالب بذلك
خلال الاسابيع الماضيه كانت اداره الرئيس
بعيده غير راضيه عن تسليم هذه المنظومه
ولكن وبحسب ما فهمنا من همم
منسقه الاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في البيت
الابيض لدى المقابله التي اجريتها معه بان
همم التغيرات على الارض على ساحه المعركه
وتحديدا همم قصف روسيا للبنيه التحتيه همم
واستهدافها المدنيين هو الذي دفع الرئيس
للموافقه على ارسال هذه المنظومه الدفاعيه
همم هناك اقرار من البيت الابيض بان
تشغيلها من قبل الاوكرانيين يتطلب بعضا من
الوقت همم انتظرا لانها منظومه دقيقه وهذا
ما ستحرص عليه الاداره الامريكيه بحسب ما
سمعنا من الرئيس الامريكي حاليا الاجتماع
ما زال مستمرا ما بين الرئيسين الامريكي
والعقراني
سوف يكون هناك
كلمه الكونجرس سوف تتم في بحدود الثالثه
والنصف بعد منتصف الليل بتوقيت مكه
المكرمه وهسهركز فيها الرئيس
شكري للشعب الامريكي على تقديم المساعدات
الامنيه مليار و850 مليون دولار قيمه
المساعدات الامنيه الجديده التي تقدمها
هذه الاداره لاوكرانيا
فادي البيطريات كانت اوكرانيا تنتظرها منذ
فتره واشنط كانت تقول انها تضع اللمسات
عليها واضح ان اللمسات قد استكملت وهي
تسلم الان همم لزنسكي ماذا في التفاصيل من
الفنتون
نعم لا شك ان هذا هو العنوان الابرز الذي
اراد ان يصدر به الرئيس
مع رئيس الاوكراني
اليوم بان الولايات المتحده سوف توفر
بطاريه باتريوت واحده حتى هذه اللحظه
للجانب الاوكراني هذه سوف تكون من ضمن
المساعده حزمه المساعدات الجديده بقيمه
مليار و850 مليون دولار ولكن تحديدا سوف
تاتي من مخزون وزاره الدفاع بمعنى ان هذه
البطاريه جاهزه سوف تتولى القوات
الامريكيه تدريب الجانب الاوكرانيه عليها
في المانيا هذا الامر سوف يستغرق بعض
الوقت وبالتالي مساله نقلها وتحويلها الى
العمل داخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه على الارجح
لا يكون خلال فتره الشتاء التي تقول
واشنطن انها دقيقه بما ان الجانب الروسي
عم استهداف البنيه التحتيه الاوكرانيه
وتحديدا الطاقه وبالتالي مساله نقل هذه
البطاريه الان الاعلان عنها يظل ذات
الطابه رمزي بما ان قدرتها سوف تظل محدوده
هي بطاريه واحده لكن هذه المنظومه وفق هذا
المسؤول الامريكي ستوفر للجانب الاوكراني
قدره دفاعيه لاسيه ضد الصواريخ البالستيه
قصيره المدى وباستطاعه الجانب الاوكرانيه
ان يستخدمها بشكل استراتيجي للدفاع عن
اهداف حيويه محدده خصوصا انما ده يصل الى
نحو 600 ميل اضافه الى ذلك قال المسؤوله
الامريكيه لنا ان واشنطن لن تعلن عن موعد
ايصال منظومه صواريخ باسيوط الى همم
اوكراني منه لا تريد ان توفر معطيات
استخباراتيه للجانب الروسي وسوف تترك هذا
الامر متى تدخل الاراضي الاوكرانيه ومتى
عمليه تبدا بالعمل اما للجانب الاوكراني
او كما قال في ختامي حديثه لنا بانها
منظومه باتريوت قد تعلن عن نفسها بنفسها
عندما تقوم باسقاط اول صاروخ او تقوم باول
اعتراض لها في الاجواء الاوكرانيه
وبالتالي هنا ينظر البنتاجون الى هذا
الامر الى انه تحول استراتيجي في طبيعه
الدعم
ورمزيا هو تاكيد على وقوف واشنطن المستمر
وراء كيف في هذه الحرب المستمره مع روسيا
ليلى
وقفي من امام البيت الابيض شكرا لكم
في الطريق الى الولايات المتحده عبر
بولندا في الشهر العاشر من الحرب يغادر
الرئيس الاوكراني
اول مره منذ نشوب الصراع تعددت اوصاف
الزياره تاريخيه ورمزيه وباللغه الاهميه
بنظره حلفائك بالنسبه لزلنسكي فهي لتعزيز
الصمود والقدرات الدفاعيه لاوكرانيا يلتقي
الرئيسان في المكتب البيضاوي
لثاني مره سبق ان استقبل بعيد
من واشنطن لانها ستحميها من روسيا وهذه
المره قولا وفعلا سيعود زرتك بحزمه
مساعدات يراد بها تغيير خريطه
يوم من الصراع المسلح العابر بتداعياته
القارات اخيرا ستشمل مساعده واشنطن
الجديده منظومه الو
اعلام امريكيه قد تصلوا الشحنه الى هناك
في غضور وقت قريب بدا ان استخدمها في
المعركه قد يستغرق شهورا فقبلها ينبغي
تدريب القوات الاوكرانيه عليها لا خير في
الزياره علقت موسكو قال المتحدث باسم
الكريم لندني بيسكوف ان شحنات اسلحه
امريكيه جديده الى اوكرانيا لن تؤدي يا
سوى الى تفاقم النزاع مع روسيا استبعد في
سكوف اي تغيير في موقف
التفاوض مع الرئيس البوتان قبل ان تحط
طائره الضيف واشنطن
يرفعوا سقف تطوير القدرات العسكريه لبلاده
ويحدد ملامحها للعام القادم وعد بانه لا
حدود ماليه لما ستقدمه الحكومه الجيش
هذا العام تجاوز واحده 91% واعاده تجهيز
افواج قوات الصواريخ الاستراتيجيه منظومات
افانكارد ما زالت متواصله
المطول اتهم وزير الدفاع الروسي سيرجي
شويغو حلف الاطلسي بارسال ضباط اركان
للمشاركه في العمليات العسكريه باوكرانيا
وفق الرئيس بوتين على مقترح وزير الدفاع
بزياده عديد القوات المسلحه الى مليون
ونصف مليون بمن فيهم
695,000 جندي متعاقد خلال هذا الاجتماع
سمعت اكثر من مره جمله رفع مستوى استعداد
الثالوث النووي الروسي بما يضمن تحقيق
التوازن الاستراتيجي
في جبهات المشتعله صوت القص والمعارك يقول
ان حرب اوكرانيا ستدخل العام الجديد
باسلحه اكثر وفرص سلام اقل تعلن موسكو
سيطرتها على مرتفعات وخطوط اماميه في
دنياز ورواياتك تتحدث عن سحب روسيا لبعض
وحداتها القتاليه من الضفه الشرقيه للنهر
دنيترو اي فرقا ستحدثه زياره لهذه الحرب
المدمر والطويله والعابره للقارات
باجنداتها واسلحتها
وينضم الان الينا من واشنطن السفير كرت
فولكر السفير الامريكي السابق لدى حلف
الناتو وكذلك ينضم الينا السفير اندريه
بكلانوف نائب رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين
الروس سيلتحق بناء بعد قليل وابدا معك
السفير كرت
اذن 300 يوم مرت على بدايه هذه الحرب كل
طرف في الواقع يحاول تسجيل نقاط في هذه
الفتره الحرجه هل يمكن القول ان زياره
زينسكي والاعلان عن تسليم اوكرانيا صواريخ
باتريات ولو كانت بطاريه واحده فقط في هذه
المرحله نقطه تسجل
لاوكرانيا لبعيد نفسه
من المهم جدا انا سعيده اوكرانيا في
الدفاع عن نفسها هجمات روسيا ضد المدنيين
الاوكرانيين ومنشات الطاقه والكهرباء
محاوله قطع الكهرباء والطاقه اييي على
المدنيين الاوكرانيين محاولات وحشيه
وبربريه
الولايات المتحده تساعد اوكرانيا في
الدفاع عن نفسها عن طريق تجهيزها بانظمه
الدفاع جويه محاوله لحمايتها هؤلاء
المدنيين من الهجمات والقارات الروسيه
واحده وتحتاج الى تدريب فتره من التدريب
هل هي فعلا كافيه لاحراز الفارق الذي
تتطلع اليه كيف هذه الحرب
هو هذا يمثل اضافيا واحده لقد قمنا بتجهيز
انظمه الدفاع عن الجويه صواريخ ستينجر
والتي تستخدمها روسي بالاضافه الى
الصواريخ الروسيه معتزال تجد طريقها الى
الاراضي الاوكرانيه هنالك اسقاط لنسبه
كبيره من الصواريخ لكن فقط حتى ولو وصلت
10 او 15% من الصواريخ الروسيه فهي يتصل
الى المدنيين وتؤثر بهم بالتالي انظمه
الدفاع الجوي لديها ارتفاع عالي ومدى بعيد
ستحاسن بشكل كبير من امكانيات اخرى في
الدفاع عن مدنها في ضوء ما نسمعه من اطراف
مختلفه سواء في اوروبا او من اوكرانيا
نفسها عن الحاجه ربما الى التوصل لحل
السلم هل نحن الان بهذه الخطوه اقرب الى
تحقيق ذلك ام القادم اسوا ميدانيا هنا
لك سلام يتحقق اليوم كل ما على روسيا ان
تقوم به هو ان توقف هجماتها على اوكرانيا
بوتن هو من يستمر على بمهاجمه اوكرانيا
ويساء يحاول السيطره على الاراضي ويقوم
بضمها ويرتكب جرائم حرب ويقوم بمهاجمه
سكان المدنيين و يهاجمه ومنشات الطاقه
والكهرباء عليه ان يتوقف فقط شكرا جزيلا
لك السفير
كورتر من واشنطن
وننتقل الى ملف انتظار ان ينضم الينا
ضيفنا روسي في ملف مرتبط بالحرب في
اوكرانيا ذكرت شبكه سي ان ان الامريكيه
نعم عفوا يبدو ان هناك موضوع يتعلق
بالتسريحات الدائره بشان منظومه
لتسليم دفعات منها الى اوكرانيا لما اثار
تساؤلات بشان الخطوه الامريكيه ودلالاتها
وهي التي عاده ما كانت تتحفظ بشان تسليم
هذه المنظومه يبدو القرار الامريكيه خاضعا
لحسابات ورهانات مرتبطه بالحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا خصوصا خلال الاشهر المقبله
لنتعرف عن قرب على منظومه باتريات
وخصائصها في هذا العرض
في عام 66 من القرن الماضي اعاده الولايات
المتحده تسميه برنامجها لتطوير صاروخ
ارجوا الى نظام الدفاع الجوي باتريوت ليتم
نشره عام 84 منظومه الصواريخ باتريوت
بنسختها الاحداث بي اي سي 3 منظومه دفاع
ارض جو تنتقل بسرعه كبيره
تتكون من اربعه اجزاء هي مركبه الرادار
وغرفه التحكم ومنصه الصواريخ اضافه الى
الصواريخ نفسها يقوم نظافه الارضي الخاص
بالمنظومه بكشف الهدف وتتبعه في دائره
قطرها نحو 80 كم ويتمكن الرادار في هذه
المنظومه من رصد 50 هدفا في ان واحد
فالصاروخ مجهز بنظام توجيه للمسار تصحيح
وهو قادر على اعتراض وتفجير الصواريخ
الباريسيه وصواريخ كروز وبعض انواع
الطائرات تحتاج منظومه باتريوت الى تسع
ثواني لاطلاق اول صاروخ بعد اكتشاف
التهديد ويمكنها اصابه اهداف جويه على
نطاق 160 كم تستطيع المنظومه اطلاق 16
صاروخا دفعه واحده يبلغ طول الواحد منها
خمسه امتار ويصل وزن بعض النماذج الى 900
كغم ويحمل راسا متفجرا قد يصل وزنه الى 90
كغراما في اغسطس اب 2008 وقعت الولايات
المتحده وبولندا اتفاقيه لانشاء مركز
البتريوت في بولندا في ردع الصواريخ
البالسيه وتعمل منظومه باتري وتعادت تامين
المجال الجوي لدول في اوروبا الشرقيه وقد
حصلت دول عديده على المنظومه تمتلك نظام
باتريوت للدفاع الجوي حاليا 12 دوله بينها
تايوان واسرائيل وكوريا الجنوبيه يرى
خبراء ان الصواريخ خط ستقدم للاوكرانيين
اضافه نوعيه في البعدين الميداني والرمزي
فهل تشكل الحضوه التي تمتعت بها كلييف لدى
واشنطن بعد شهور من مطالباتها بهذه
الصواريخ منعطفا في الحرب الدائره منذ
ازيد من 300 يوم
وفي المقابل تضمنا كلام الرئيس الروسي
فيلاديمير بوتين وزيري دفاعه سيرجي شويجو
اليوم حديثا عن اسلحه النوعيه من صواريخ
صوتيه وتجهيزات عسكريه النوويه وحتى انضمت
مراقبه فضائيه قدرات هذه الاسلحه
والتجهيزات العسكريه وميزاتها ان نتعرف
عليها في هذا الدقيق
باسلحه لا مثيل لها في العالم وفق وصف
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مير بوتين تعزز قدره
القوات الروسيه ابرز تلك الاسلحه صاروخ
صارمات الذي يسميه الروس بملك الصواريخ
بين 10,000
و18000 كلم وهو قادر على حمل عشره رؤوس
النوويه بقدره تدميريه عاليه
تحت الارض صاروخ اخر اعلن الرئيس الروسي
عزمه البدء باستخدامه مطلع العام المقبل
ضمن تسليح الجيش الروسي هو صاروخ السيركن
الفرض الصوتي
سرعه الصوت في تسعه اضعاف
بحري يطلق من الغواصات والسفن وقادر على
اصابه اهداف حتى مسافه الكيلو متر سرعه
الصاروخ الهائله تمنحه ميزه تصاحب من
تتبعها او اعتراضه من انظمه اعتراض
الصواريخها
موازي له الدفاع الروسي يرجى تشويكو فقال
ان الثالوث النووي الروسي لديه جاهزيه
عاليه بفضل تزويد القوات باحدث الاسلحه
ويقصد تشويغو بالثالث النووي منصات اطلاق
الصواريخ النوويه سواء الارضيه المكشوفه
منها والمخبائه والبحريه من غواصات وسفن
والجويه عبر القاذفات الاستراتيجيه
والطائرات كما اعلنت شويغو اطلاق المركبه
الفضائيه السادسه كوبل وتعني القبه وهي
تتيح مراقبه مستمره للمناطق المحتمل
استهدافها بالصواريخ في النصف الشمالي من
الارض
[موسيقى]
والان ينضم الينا من موسكو السفير اندرويد
اهلا بك في الحصاد اذن هذا الاستقبال في
واشنطن
والاعلان عن تسليمه
بطاريه بيتريوت طبعا بعد تدريب القوات
عليها
الى اي درجه يغير قواعد اللعبه بالنسبه
لمسكو
هي انظمه قديمه ليست بالجديده ونحن راينا
انها لم تكن فعال في
الهجمات
المنشات التي كانت تتواجد فيه
السعوديه عندما هاجمها الحوثيين ولذلك
اليوم همم
النتيجه التي سوف يحصلون عليها ليست كبيره
جدي ونحن وننظر الى هذا بجديه من قبل
الولايات المتحده اليوم الرئيس
ان اقول شيء غير مسبوق من الاجراءات في
تقويه القوات العسكريه لروسيا ترايليه
والحديث هنا ليس عن الاعمال العسكريه في
اوكرانيا بل هنا عن مساحه عسكريه في
التحضير العسكري واسع جدا لامكانيات
عسكريه موجهه ضد اوروبا كلها في حاله اي
النزاعات هذه هي الاوضاع الان والحرف
تخترب اكثر واكثر واكد تصبح اوروبيه او
تصبح عالميه وهذا ليس الخيار الذي نقوم به
ولكن هذا ما نستعد له
ولكن في الوقت نفسه هناك حديث عن محاولات
لانهاء الحرب سلميا بهذا الكلام شرط اليه
وما تقوم به مصكو حاليا هل اغلق الباب
تماما من جانب موسكو
بشان اي جهود سلميه
يومها
لا ارى في الوقت الحالي
في اي مفاوضات او اعمال دبلوماسيه ناجحه
ليس هناك اي اسس لهذا
واذا تغيرت الاوضاع عند هاتها سوف نبدا
بالحديث عن الفراص السلميه ليس هناك اي
فرصه لهذا الان هو لكن همم
الاختلافات هنا كبيره جدا
لدرجه ان ليس هناك فرص حقيقيه لا حوار
رئيس جمعيه الدبلوماسيين الروس شكرا لك
والان ينضم الينا من عمان اللواء فايز
الدويري الخبير العسكري والستراتيجي
دلوقت ونحن نتابع الطرفين كل جهات تعتقد
انها الان احرزت يعني نقطه في مرماها
الاوكرانيين يحصلون على بطاريه من البيترس
والروس سي يوظفون كل ما لديهم ملك
الصواريخ كما يسمونه
لي مواجهه اي تقدم عسكري من الجانب الاخر
يعني كيف يضع هذا همم موضوع الحرب الان
الدائره على الارض اين نحن
يعني يعني الان هذا يعني فتح افاق ايه او
الافق الزمني
لاستمرار هذه الحرب وبالتالي رصد 45 مليار
من قبل الاداره الامريكيه
يعلي لعام 2023 يعني ان عام 2023 ضمن
الاطار الزمني وبالتالي هذه الحرب طويله
ومستمره ومكلفه خطاب الرئيس الروسي تقريبا
كان موجه الى القوات المسلحه الروسيه الى
اوكرانيا الى الغرب تحدث عن امور تخص
القوات الروسيه كشفت جوانب ضعف في الاذاعه
الميداني وفتحت افاق
للتفاؤل وتطوير القدرات عندما يتحدث عن
الصواريخ اللي صارت الصوتيه الثالوث
الاستراتيجي توظيف الطائرات المسيره توظيف
الذكاء الاصطناعي همم تطوير القدرات
لامداد لوجستي والعمليات اذا هي رسائل
متعدده لكن قابلها بالمقابل
تجامن زياره الرئيس زيرنسكي في يوم خطاب
الرئيس بوتن وهذه لها دلالتها الرمزيه
الحديث عن باتريوت تم اعطاءه مساءا كبيره
جدا انا اقول مرسه واحده لن تغير الكثير
قد تستخدم للدفاع عن كيف لن تغير في
الامور بصوره كبيره لن تستخدم ضد الطائرات
المسيره بسبب كلفه الصواريخ ولكن اهميه
هذا القرار ياتي من كسر قاعده الخطوط
الحمراء كان صواريخ باتريو
دبابات ابرامز الطائرات المجنحه هي مارس
300 كلم صواريخ 165 كلم تقع خلف الخط
الاحمر الان تم كسر هذا الخط
بالموافق على صواريخ باتريت ولو بطاريه
واحده وانت اشارتي الى ممكن وصول بطاريات
لاحقا اذا دعيني اقول الموافقه على
باتريوت قد تعني الموافق على همارس 300 اي
قذف داخل الروسي قصف جزيره القرم قد يعني
الموافقه على طائرات اف 16 مستقبلا
وتقريبا الثلاثه او امور مترابطه متزامنه
باتريوت ابرامز
وطائرات اف 16 هذا ما كان يطالب به
الرئيسكي الان حصل على الطلب الاول ما
يمنع ان يحصل على الطلب الثاني
والثالثه من عمان شكرا
واسعا للكشف عن ظروف تمكن ايران من
استخدام قطع التكنولوجيه غربيه منها اشباه
مواصلات امريكيات في صناعه طائراتها
المسيره التي تتهمها بتوريدها لروسيا
واضافت انه بعد فحص عدد من الطائرات
المسيره التي اسقطتها القوه الاوكرانيه
تبين ان 82% من مكوناتها صنعتها شركه
امريكيه واظهر الفحص ان المسيارات
الايرانيه تحتوي اجهزه استشعار تكتكيه
عاليه الجوده
واشباه موصلات غربيه كما بين الفحص ان
مكونات هذه الوسينات الايرانيه صنعت من
قبل 70 شركه في 13 بلدا وان احداها تحتوي
بطا يابانيه ومحرك النمساويا واشباه
مواصلات امريكيه
وبحسب السي ان ان فانما يزيد من مخاوف
الاداره الامريكيه ان ايران بدات تنقل هذه
التكنولوجيا الى روسيا التي تستعد بدورها
لفتح مصنع للمسيرات
على اي حال سيكون لنا نقاش اوسع بعد قليل
في فقره في المتابعه وذلك الحديث عن
المسيرات الايرانيه وتحقيقات الامريكيه
والقيود المزمع فرضها على صادرات مرتبطه
بالامر
[موسيقى]
في بيجيني تبحث موسكو افقامه تصفها
بالشراكه غير المحدوده هذا الحديث كان في
لقاء جمع الرئيس الصيني شيجن بناء برئيس
مجلس الامن الروسي ديمتري مدفيدف وسائل
الاعلام صينيه قالت ان الرئيس شيء اكد لمد
بيدف ان تطوير شركه استراتيجيه بين الصين
وروسيا خيار استراتيجيون طويل الامد يقوم
به البلدان وفقا لظروفهم الوطن
بلا حدود هكذا تريد
لشركته الشامله ان تكون
نم التعاون العسكريه بين الجانبين بشكل
اللافع في الشهور الاخيره هنا في مقاطعه
شرقيه الصين تجري القوات البحريه الصينيه
والروسيه مناوراتها المشتركه الاحداث على
مدى اسبوع
العالمي والقطب الجاذبه لتحالفاته لكن هل
لتوقيت المناورات من دلاله يسال مهتمون
بالمساله
مهتمون غيرهم يستوقفهم نشاط سياسي متزامن
انتهى بنائب رئيس مجلس الامن الروسي في
بيت بعد لقائه لمتر مدفيدف اكد رئيس الصين
ان تطوير شراكه استراتيجيه مع روسيا خيار
استراتيجي طويل الاماد
لن تعدم مشككين غربيين هنا في ان تلك
الشراكه لا حدود لها حقا في روسيا هي
الساعه منذ بدء حربها على اوكرانيا لتمثيل
روابطها الاقتصاديه والسياسيه والامنيه مع
الصين
فهل تفعل ذلك من مطلق الرؤيه الروسيه
الصينيه المشتركه الناشده نظاما عالميا
عاجلا متعدد الاقطاب ام هل تحاول موسكو
تعويض خسارتها العلاقات والاسواق الغربيه
بعد حربها على اوكرانيا
توصف بحرب الطاقه مع الغرب كما ان
العقوبات الدوليه وضعت اقتصاد بلاده تحت
باطن شديد
بقوه سيبيريا سيحل الخط بذلك محل خط
انابيب نور ستريم اثنان الذي يضخ الغاز
الى اوروبا ويواجه عقوبات بعد اندلاع حرب
اوكرانيا
قد يشعر ذلك حلفاء كيف الغربيين بان
بيجينغ تحد من اثر عقوباتهم على موسكو
ومحاولتهم عزلها دوليه ليس تماما الصينيون
ليس هو كمخاطره فهم لم يؤيد صراحه للحرب
على اوكرانيا بل يقر الروس انفسهم بوجود
اسئله ومخاوف فصيليه بشان تلك
الحربائها المتضاده رؤاهم بحذر شديد تجدها
تعمل على تمثيل الصلات مع الشريك الروسي
وتساعد في تجنيب اقتصاده لانهيار وتجدها
في الوقت عينه تولي اهميه اكبر لما صالحها
مع الغرب فذاك ما يضمن بقاء اقتصادها قويا
عبر تجاره والصادرات والاستثمارات
هذا وقال منسق للاتصالات الاستراتيجيه في
مجلس الامن القوميه الامريكيه جون كربي
الى بلاده لاحظت زياده في التعاون والحوار
بين روسيا والصين وانها تراقب ذلك عن كثب
واضاف كربي في لقاء مع الجزيره انا واشنطن
واثقه من قدرتها على الدفاع عن مصالحها
الامنيه حول العالم وفق تعبيره
راينا زياده في التعاون والتكامل والحوار
بين روسيا والصين ولدينا ثقه كبيره في
قدرتنا على الدفاع عن مصالحنا الامنيه
القوميه سواء في منطقه المحيطين الهادئ
والهندي او حول العالم
سوبر 7
وينضم الان الينا من اصل الدكتور جلانديسن
استاذه العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه ساوث
ايست في النرويج اهلا وسهلا بك معنا في
الحصاد اذن هذه الشراكه التي نتطلع اليها
بين الصين وروسيا ونتطلع لها على ما يجري
نريد ان نفهمها ما هي حدودها سواء بالنسبه
لبيجين او بالنسبه لموسكو
بالتالي فانه
ليس الامر متعلقا بتحالف بسيط ضد الولايات
المتحده لكن الامور اهم من ذلك كما تحاول
الصين وروسيا القيام به هو جاد
هنا تحتيه عالميه اقتصاديه بمعنات تطوير
انظمه ومراكز
للتكنولوجيا والاقتصاد والصناعات وايضا
ممرات للنقل وخاصه في مسالته همم مبادره
الحزام
والطريق وايضا الدفع بالعملات المحليه
وانظمه تامين واجراء تامين جديده وفوق ذلك
هو ان يتقل الاعتمادها على الولايات
المتحده اوروبا
بالتالي ببساطه لان
السيطره الامريكيه وكانها في اصول هنا لك
زياده همم بالعدائيه فيما
يتعلقوبات الاقتصاديه ضد همم
لديه مواقف معاديه للولايات المتحده
بالتاليه روسيا وسيم تحاول تحاولاني ان
تحميها انفسهما من اي عقوبات وتاثيرات
اقتصاديه قادمه من الولايات المتحده
وهل ترى فعلا ان الصين ستدخل في
استراتيجيه طويله الامد مع روسيا امن ان
الصبرهم الاستراتيجي قد ينفذ كما قد يعتقد
البعض ان الصبر الامريكي ايضا
اعتقد
ان هذه شراكه لا غنى عنها هم الحلفاء
الاهم لبعضهم البعض الصين لديها القوه
التكنولوجيه روسيا من الجانب الاخر لديها
كميات هائله من الموارد اذا ما تحالفها
داري البلدان مع بعضهما البعض سيتمكناني
من موجهه
بنى تحتيه
الاقتصاديه الامريكيه هذه قوه اقتصاديه
وقوه عسكريه لان الولايات المتحده مثلا
تطلق حربا بالوكاله ضد روسيا وايضا
الولايات المتحده بالقرب من السواحل
الصينيه تحاول ان تعيق مساله الضمه
بالتالي هنالك حاجه من البلدين لل- للبنا
التحتيه الاقتصاديه وايضا لتطويل نظام
دولي جديد يعتمد الذي كان يع دائما على
السيطره الامريكيه بالتالي هم يشيرون الى
هذه الشركه على انها الشراكه الاعظم وهما
اللي يحاوران لجذب الدول الاخرى في
المنطقه مثلا بامكاننا ننظر ينظر الى دول
البريكس مثلا الهند ايران قد تكون مهتمه
السعوديه قد تكون من ضمن في هذه الشراكه
بالتالي هنالك تجمعات جديده تتشكل الان
هذا الامر بالتاكيد يثير قلق الولايات
المتحده بالتالي تزداد عدائيتها وهذا امر
المتوقع
استاذ العلاقات الدوليه في جامعه لك
[موسيقى]
قررت اسرائيل احتجاز جثمان الاسير
الفلسطيني ناصر ابو حميد
وعدم تسليمه لاهله بعد استشهاده اجراء
تدهوري حالته الصحيه وقالت اسرائيلينا
القرار ياتي لضروره تتعلق بمفاوضات صفقات
تبادل الاسرى وقد لقى القرار الاسرائيلي
تمديدا فلسطينيا
لتحرك دولي وقررت عائله الاسير الشهيد عدم
فتح بيت عزاء في استشهاد نجلها الا بعد ان
تفرج سلطات الاحتلال عن جثمانه
رغم معاناته لاكثر من عام كامل من مرض
السرطان واعتقاله لنحول الثلثي عمره
البالغي 50 عاما تقرر اسرائيل احتجاز
الجثمان الاسير ناصر ابو حميد وحرمان اهله
من دفنه والقاء نظره الوداع الاخيره عليه
هيئه الاسرار كانت قد حمل السلطات
الاحتلال مسؤوليه وفاته بسبب سياسه
الاهمال الطبي المتعمد في سجونها القرار
جاء من وزير الدفاع
الاسرائيليانس بعد تقدير الموقف الامني
وبتوصيات من الجهات الامنيه والجيش
وتذرعن بما وصفها بيان صادر عن مكتبه
بضرورات تتعلق بالمفاوضات على عقد صفقه
تبادل الاسرى والمفقودين الاسرائيليين
الخطوه الاسرائيليه سرعان ما لاقت ردود
فعل فلسطينيه
ادانت القرار واعتبرته معانا في جريمه
الاحتلال بحق الشهيد اما حركه حماس فقالت
ان الاحتلال يخالف ابسط القوانين والاعراف
الدوليه وينتهي كل معايير حقوق الانسان في
حين وصف الامين العام لحركه المبادره
الوطنيه الفلسطينيه مصطفى البرغوثي القرار
الاسرائي هي بالمجرم وحمل المجتمع الدولي
مسؤوليه الصمت اما عائله الاسير ناصر ابو
حميد فقررت عدم فتح بيت عزاء لنجلها الا
بعد ان تقوم سلطات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
بالافراج عن جثمانه ليدفن حسب عاداته
وتقاليد الفلسطينيين
وقيامنا
يليق بقائد مناطل مثل ناصر ابو حميد
لا يعد احتجاز وجثامين الشهداء والاسرى
الفلسطينيين سياسه جديده للسلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي فهي حتى الان تحتجث ميناء 10
اسرار قضوا خلف زنازينها فضلا عن جثامين
نحو 90 شهيدا سقطوا خلال اشتباكات وعمليات
عسكريه في الضفه الغربيه منذ عوده الجيش
الاسرائيلي للسياسه احتجاز الجثامين عام
ينضم الينا من غزه الدكتور صالح النعامي
الخبير في الشؤون الاسرائيليه اهلا بك
دكتور في الحصاد هذه الاستراتيجيه التي
نتحدث عنها عدم تسليم الجثمان لاهل الفقيد
في النهايه
ليس بالامر الجديد ولكن هناك نقطه هنا
ربما نتوقف عندها الاعلان بهذه الصوره
هل له دلاله معينه
100 شهيد فلسطيني تحت جز- اا اسرائيل
جثامينهم همم منذ اكثر من 12 عام تقريبا
اااه هذا من ناحيه من الناحيه الثانيه
طبعا هناك التوقيت له دلاله دلاله تكفون
في انه الحكومه المنتهيه ولايتها الحكومه
همم لبيد همم والاحزاب التي تشارك فيها
تريد ان تكرس انطباعا لدى الراي العام
الصهيوني بانها ليست اقل اجراما وليست اقل
لتطرفا من الحكومه القادمه التي يتحدث
الناس عن تطرفها همم هذا من ناحيه الثالثه
هناك همم للاسف الشديد ما يشجع اسرائيل
على هذا على هذا الامر يعني يعني همم يدعو
الناس الى الى الرد على هذا السلوك
الاجرامي وتدخل دولي يحدث هذا هذه الدعوات
في الوقت الذي فاصل للاسف الشديد السلطه
الفلسطينيه نمط علاقتها القائم حاليا على
التعاون الامني وعدم تحريك دعاوى ضد
اسرائيل في المحافل الدوليه بشكل يشجي
اثمانا الذي اتخذ هذا القرار بنجانس وزير
الحرب الصين هو الذي يتباهى يوميا بفعاليه
التعاون الامن معجزه السلطه الفلسطينيه
وبالتالي ما لم يحدث تغيير على بيئه
العلاقه ما بين السلطه الفلسطينيه والكيان
الصهيوني للاسف الشديد نحنا همم نطلع
وسنتعرض لكثير من هذه المظاهر الاجراميه
التي بالمناسبه يعني دخلت الان في سياق
المناسبات
نعم هل ترى مؤشر دكتور لاي تغير في هذه
العلاقه كما ذكرت انت جالس في النهايه جزء
من حكومه يعني قدم في الداخل وقدم خارج
الباب اذن من اي علاقه همم يمكن ان يتحدث
عنها في هذه الفتره
استاذ ليلى انا في تقديري انه الامر
الخطير في هذا في هذا الموضوع هو خطه وزير
الامن الوطني بين هلالين القادم اتمار بين
كبير ثمار بين كبير كما تعلمون كوزير
الامن الداخل الى الامن الوطني بين اهللين
هو مسؤول عن مصلحه السجون وهو قد اعلن
بشكل واضح وصريح ان لديه خطه
لدفع لان مصادره الحقوق الكثير من الحقوق
التي انجزها الاسرى في سجون الاحتلال
بتضحيات عظيمه وبالتالي ما لم يحدث ما لم
تحدث هناك رد فعل فلسطينيه قويه يعني تقني
صانع القرار في اسرائيل القادم بانه
مواصله وتطبيق هذه الخطه همم التي تستهدف
الاسرى الفلسطينيين فانه ما لم يتم اقناعه
بهذا الامر برده الفعل الفلسطينيه فاننا
للاسف الشديد همم يعني همم سنجد الكثير من
الخطوات التي تفاقم وضع الاسرى همم تدهور
يعني الاسير ابو حميد هو الاسير همم 77
الذي توفي بسبب الاهمال الطبي في داخل
السجون الاحتلال هناك 70 اسير فلسطيني
ينتظرون همم اجراء عمليه جراحيه عاجله من
ضمن عام 2015 هناك 635 اسير فلسطيني مرض
يعانون من امراض مزمنه في داخل السجون
سلطه همم مصلحه السجون تصر على الابقاء
على اجهزه ال- ال- تصدر الاشعاع التي يجمع
المراقبون على ان تتسبب في كثير من
الحالات السرطان التي امراض السرطان التي
يصيب بها الاسرى الدكتور صالح النعامي
خبير في شان الاسرائيلي شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
استعانه الحكومه البريطانيه من جنود الجيش
لقياده سيارات الاسعاف وذلك بدلا من
طواقمها الاصليه المدربه عن العمل الاضراب
الذي يشارك فيه نحو عشره الاف من طواقم
الاسعاف في انجلترا
بعد ما فشلت محادثات اللحظه الاخيره بين
الحكومه والنقابات
يوم الاخر
شديد الحساسيه مرفق الاسعاف
لنا اسبابه للاشتراك في الاضراب
وان كان هذا هو السبب الرئيسي لكن
في العاملين
نقابات ثلاث للمسعفين في انجلترا وويلز
تشاركه في الاضراب كان في اكبرها تهامه
الحكومه لها بتعريض حياه الناس للخطر
والتقاعس عن الترتيب الجيد لتفادي تعطل
الخدمات في اثناء الاضراب تقول النقابات
الثلاثه ان عرض الحكومه لزياده الاجور
ينعم عن عدم تقدير لهم بعد نحو عقد من
تجميد الاجور وفي ايونه توحش فيها غلاء
الاسعار
على مطالب المطربين وقال انه يركز الان
على اجراءات الطوارئ لتعويض النقص ابرز
هذه الاجراءات استخدام جنود القوات
المسلحه محل المساعدين المطربين اجراء لقد
انتقادات من اطراف المعارضه قطاع الصحه
ومرفق الاسعاف في بريطانيا يلقياني دعما
كبيرا في الشارع
قدموا لنا الكثير من الخدمات سندوا الناس
خلال جائتكورونا لابد ان لديهم اسبابهم
للاضراب
اضراب جاء غادات يوم ثاني من اكبر اضراب
لطواقم التمريض في تاريخ بريطانيا وجاء
كلاهما تزامنا مع اضرابات متكرره في
قطاعات عده توازيا وتتاليا حتى باتت
الاضرابات تهدد بافساد موسم الاعياد الاول
المسموح فيه بالسفر دون قيود في ثلاثه
اعوام بسبب جائعه كورونا
بدخول طواقم الاسعاف على خط الاضرابات
تتعمق المشاكل التي تعصف بالقطاع الصحي في
بريطانيا سيناريو يحذر كثيرون حتى من داخل
حزب المحافظين من خطورته على المواطن
المثقلي باعباء التضخم القاسيه وعلى شعبيه
الحزب الحاكم في البلاد منذ اثني عشر عاما
اسد الله الصاوي الجزيره لندن
[موسيقى]
لن العوده الى موضوع المسيرات الايرانيه
وما ذكرته شبكه السي ان ان الاداره
الامريكيه بدات تحقيقا واسعا للكشف عن
ظروف تمكن ايران من استخدام قطع تكنولوجيه
غربيه في صناعه الطائراتها المسيره التي
تتهمتها بتوريدها لروسيا نتعارف الان على
ابرز هذه المسايرات شاهد
136 او طائره الكاميكازي كما تعرف والتي
تزن نحو 200 كيلو جرام وتعد رخيصه نسبيا
تقدر قيمتها ب 20 الى 50,000 دولار
هذه المسيرات تطلق على شكل اسراب كما
تلاحظون يجري عاده اعتراض عدد كبير منها
ولكن نجاح مسيره او اثنتين في الوصول الى
الهدف يعتبر كافيا في العاده لاحداث دمار
من النوع الكبير المسيره الاخرى التي تشير
تقارير الى ان ايران باعتها لروسيا في هي
مهاجر سته
وهذه الوسيله يبلغ وزنها نحو 600 كغم وهي
قادره على الطيران لمده اثنتين 10 ساعات
وتستخدم في مهام الاستطلاع والهجوم
مسيره مهاجر سته مجهزه بكاميرا حراريه
وبصريه وتحمل اربع قنابل ذكيه دقيقه
التقارير تشير الى ان روسيا طلبت شراء
مسيرات ابابيل ثلاثه ويمكن لهذه المسايرات
حمل قنبلتين مواجهتين براس حربي وزنه نحو
كيلو جرامين يصل مداه الى نحو سته
كيلومترات ويمكنها التحليق لنحو ثماني
ساعات على ارتفاع خمسه كيلومترات بهذه
الطائره عدت نسخ يمكن لبعضها الطيران
بسرعه 300 كلم في الساعه
روسيا ااا تقول طبعا هذا الكلام او بسرعه
على انها اييي ليس لها ولم تعلن انها
تستلمها من ايران ولكن ايران تقول ان
صناعه المسايرات محليه الخبراء يرون ان
طهران اعتمدت في صناعه هذه المسيرات على
ما يعرف بالهندسه العكسيه وذلك من خلال
الاستنساخ التكنولوجيا والمحركات وغيرها
طبعا
التقارير تشير الى ان مسيره شاهد
171 مثلا هي نموذج ايراني عن الطائره
الامريكيه اركيو 170 والتي اسقطتها ايران
عام 2011 وهي تستخدم همم في العاده لاغراض
تجسس وقد تمكنت ايران من فك التكنولوجيا
الخاصه بها ثم اعادت تصنيعها باستخدام
الهندسه العكسيه
خبراء ينوهون الى ان ايران
اشتقنا طائره كوثر مستفيده من طائره اف 15
او خمسه اي تايجر اثنان
وهذه الطائره الامريكيه تمكنت ايران من ان
تستغلها من خلال الاستنساخ الالكتروني
اللي الكترونيات الطيران ولا اجهزه
الاستشعار داخل هذه الطائره
مسيرات ابابيل
ثلاثه تحديدا
الابحاث تشير الى انها مستنسخه من الطائره
الجنوب افريقيه وهي سيكر تو دي هذه
الطائره حصلت ايران على بعض نسخها عام
2005 ثم بدات انتاجها باستخدام الهندسه
العكسيه
سنحاول ان نفهم ما الذي يعنيه تحديدا هذا
الاعلان الذي همم صرحت به سي ان ان من
ضيفنا في ولايه بنسلفانيا الدكتور مايكل
بول استاذ العلوم السياسيه في جامعه روترز
ومؤلف كتاب عصر المسيارات
كيف ستغير تكنولوجيا المسيرات الحرب
والسلام هذا هو عنوان الكتاب اهلا وسهلا
بك دكتور
ربما يعني اعتقد انه كان
ماء بارد يصب على الولايات المتحده ما
قامت سانا بالاعلان عنه ان المسيرات التي
تقصف اوكرانيا حاليا ااه وهي بحسب
الاتهامات مسيرات تقول انها ايرانيات
الصنع هناك اجهزه
وتتضمن اجزاء هي في الواقع غربيه الصنع
ومن الولايات المتحده نفسها
ماذا يعني
في الحرب في اوكرانيا ان روسيا قد استنفذت
الكثير من
مخزونها من المسيرات بالتالي لا تملك
المزيد لكي تستمر بحر بها الجويه لان
اوكرانيا اصبحت بتعتمد على ايران للدعم
هذه المسيار لان ايران هي مصدر كبير وخاصه
بالنسبه لشاهد وبعدين لكن ما نراه اليوم
انهما وجدنا من مسيره شاهد التي تم
اصداقها ان هناك عناصر او اجزاء مصنوعه في
الخارج مثلا المستشعرات
مواصلات وهذا غير قانوني حسب القانون
الولايه الولايات المتحده واداره قررت
انها ستقوم بتطبيق
وتشكيل لجنه ستنظر وتحقق في كيفيه حصول
ذلك ودراسه ممارسات الشركات الامريكيه
لضمان ان هذه الاجزاء لا تنتهي في المس
مراتي الايرانيه والتي يتم شرائها من قبل
روسيا وتهاجم بها اوكرانيا
دكتور بويل الى اي حد فعلا يمكن السيطره
على تصدير التكنولوجيا والتي كما شاهدنا
قبل قليل تستنسخ في عده اماكن هل فعلا
يمكن وضع هذا الامر تحت السيطره بشكل كبير
جدا السيطره على هذه الامور المشكله
الاساسيه ان هنالك اجزاء كبيره من الاجزاء
التي تم تحديدها في المسارات الايرانيه
يتم استخدامها في القطاع التجاري قد تكون
موجوده وشرائها من
سيارات التجاريه من الصعب جدا السيطره على
التسرب مثل هذه التكنولوجيات ايضا الطريقه
التي يتم ارسال هذه التكنولوجيا الى ايران
لان هنالك اتفاقيات ثنائيه وغير رئيسيه
مثلا مع شركات قد يكون هنالك شركات
امريكيه لديها همم مثلا همم
اذن وشركات في الصين وبالتالي تنتهي لدى
ايران بالتالي
غربجه مشكله في وقت عصيبه في فرض عقوبات
افضل ما باستطاعتي ان تقوم به اداره بيدا
ان تضع ضغطنا على همم على الشركات
الامريكيه وشركات الاوروبيه لرؤيه وف نوع
من القيود على
الشركات والمصانع في هونج مثلا
مؤلف كتاب عصر المسيرات شكرا لك جزيلا
وشكرا لكم على المتابعه
[موسيقى]